well the first part of it was really fun
and like joyful because I love the
stories and really easy to adapt the
first two stories and I'd say they're
very close to the original um and then
the challenge was kind of like was
writing the climax and the ending and
like weaving all the stories together so
they didn't feel like separate but they
actually built into like a full feature
length story um so that part I ended up
spending a lot of time with an AI
colleague wrote you know several maybe
seven or eight dress over the course of
a year um and at some one point last
summer I went to Palo Alto do some
research and interviewed a bunch of tech
people and like kind of got the idea for
those father characters and I think that
really helped me like bring it all
together um so it was like easy in a way
because the stories are very cinematic
and then it was just hard to like you
know give it a fool like narrative arc
and then and now I think it's there so
it's good you know I guess this is
amazing because when you see the
IndieGoGo campaign you don't necessarily
realize like how much work that that all
you guys have already put in I mean this
is this is a couple years worth of work
that you guys already have on the table
yeah definitely like I think the scripts
are really good and like people involved
he really worked really hard on them and
so that's exciting um do you do send
several drafts back and forth with James
and some other people yeah over yeah I
sent several drafts to James and then
two months ago we'd had a reading which
was really fun what he and I am
shrinking the producer just kind of SAT
um together and he read a lot of the
characters and we read it out loud and
that was great and then you know gave me
notes and so we've had like several back
and forth exchanges